Y ahora nos piden que simplifiquemos esta resta de estos dos polinomios,
entonces voy a volver a escribir esta resta de polinomios,
deshaciéndome de todos los paréntesis, como le tenga que hacer para deshacerme de ellos. Por aquí tenemos 16x
16x más 14
más 14, nos deshicimos
súper bien de estos 2 paréntesis por que en realidad estos 2 paréntesis
no están modificando en lo más mínimo a lo que tienen adentro, no están cambiando las operaciones, entonces simplemente pueden desaparecer.
Ahora con estos paréntesis tenemos que tener mucho más cuidado por que tenemos un símbolo de menos aquí adelante.
¿Ok? Entonces estamos restando
todos los términos que estén adentro de este paréntesis, así es que si queremos quitar estos paréntesis
tenemos que distribuir el menos a cada uno de los términos.
Entonces nos va a quedar -3x cuadrada y luego -"x"
- "x" por que el "x" está dentro del paréntesis entonces, queremos
restarlo ¿ok? También podemos pensar que aquí estemos
sumando un -1 por todo el paréntesis entonces, tenemos que -1 por 3x cuadrada más
- 1 por "x" más -1por -9, que es nuestro siguiente término, menos por menos nos da más
entonces queda más 9
que en realidad es un menos -9 bien, entonces, ya por fin nos deshicimos de esos paréntesis.
Y ahora pues queremos
simplificarlo, entonces vamos a agrupar todos los términos que podamos ¿Ok? Para que nos quede bonito el polinomio
lo que tenemos que hacer es empezar con los términos que tengan el grado más grande de la variable "x".
¿Ok? En este caso es "x" al cuadrado así es que vamos a buscar todos los términos que tengan "x" cuadrada
que pues nada más es este.
Entonces tenemos por aquí -3x
cuadrada y nos seguimos con los términos que tengan al siguiente
grado más grande de "x" ¿Ok? Como ya terminamos con "x" al cuadrado
entonces nos toca buscar a los términos que tengan "x" a la 1 o sea simplemente "x",
así es que buscamos, este es uno de esos términos, éste no
éste también tienen una sola "x" y éste tampoco
entonces, pues vamos a sumarlos. Aquí tenemos más 16x más
- "x" y si tenemos
16 de una cosa y - 1 de esa misma cosa, entonces en realidad tenemos
15 de esa cosa que es "x" y bueno vamos con los siguientes términos que tengan el
siguiente grado más grande de "x" ¿Ok? Aquí tenemos "x" a la 1 entonces lo que le sigue es "x" a la cero, o sea 1.
Así es que estamos buscando a todas las constantes y pues esas son estas 2 que son los términos que sobran
entonces 14 más 9 eso es 23
y listo hemos terminado.